I haven't felt the pain that sharp in a
while
Shaquille O'Neal fought back tears on
Tuesday night mourning the death of his
friend and teammate Kobe Bryant you know
just makes me think that and in life
sometimes instead of holding them back
certain thing we should just do
Shaq was emotional sitting center court
inside the Staples Center as part of
TNT's tribute to the former Los Angeles
Lakers star a man's will be
attached together
for what we did when it comes to the
inside the lines and when I said much so
we did Kobe and his 13 year old daughter
Gianna were among nine people killed in
a helicopter accident on Sunday Shaq
recalled the moment he learned about the
tragic news from his nephew of enough
who comes in
crying he showed me his phone and I
snapped at him suddenly get off my face
get away from you know we live in a
world where anything could be
photoshopped
anything could be hoaxed I didn't want
to believe it and then I got a call from
you Charles Kenny everybody called me
and then we found out it was coming from
the 47 year old added that the news hit
him extra hard because he lost his
younger sister to cancer in October lost
my sister and now I lost a little
brother Shaq said the final blow was
when he found out Gianna was on the
helicopter - we up here we work a lot
and I think a lot of times we take stuff
and granite like I don't talk to you
guys as much that much as I need to
the fact that uh we're not going to be
able to joke at his Hall of Fame
ceremony go to the beach you can't get
back I wish I could just say something
to him and Shaq explained how this
tragedy has caused a shift in him it
definitely changes me I have to because
I work a lot you guys know what I do I
work probably more than the average guy
but I just really have to now just take
time to just call and say I love you
Rick Fox finally called me said man I
like it so I'm gonna try to do a better
job just reaching out just talking to
the people rather than always
procrastinating because you never know
on Sunday false reports circulated that
Shaq and Kobes former Lakers teammate
Rick Fox was one of the nine passengers
to die in the crash that killed Kobe
I'm calling Rick he's not answering so
now what's going on Rick also appeared
on the TNT tribute and opened up about
how the inaccurate reports affected his
loved ones my family went through in the
midst of all of this something I
couldn't have imagined them experiencing
you know one of my my daughter's
greatest fears is finding out that a
parent or one of her parents would be
lost through social media instead of
from you know a loved one or a family
member and and you know she fortunately
called me and we just were talking and
crying about the news of Kobe Rick said
the phone started ringing off the hook
and he assumed it was because people
were wanting to talk to him about Kobe
it wasn't until his best friend called
that he finally picked up the phone I
answered it and I said hey man this is
crazy about Kobe and he just was bawling
and I started crying and he was like
you're alive and I'm thinking well yeah
like what do you mean
and he and it was in that moment that my
phone just started going and my mom and
my sister and my brother and and so look
this is this has been this has been a
lot to the process from all of us it
shook a lot of people in my life after
filming for the special wrapped shack
led a champ for his friend outside of
the Staples Center where fans were
gathered to mourn
[Music]
[Applause]
et will continue to be here to bring you
all the latest on this story until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
you